[Música]
sábado 12 de diciembre de 2020 primer
día de la decimoctava edición de la
semana de la moda de la cara frente a la
estación de tren un minibús espera a las
modelos que tienen que ir al lugar del
desfile a unos 70 kilómetros al este de
las ciudades
el pulmón canceló el evento que se
suponía iba a tener lugar mañana debido
a las restricciones como resultado lo
que se esperaba fueron dos días se
condensará en un día es decir unas horas
antes del evento tienes que adaptarte
totalmente es hora de que el equipo se
ponga al día y trabaje con los que
tenemos para asegurarnos de que el
proceso se desarrolle sin problemas
la semana de la moda de dakar y va a
tener una duración de dos días el primer
día 12 diseñadores debían presentar sus
colecciones el segundo 9 de ellos debían
desfilar en un gran hotel de la ciudad
pero las nuevas medidas sanitarias
adoptadas por las autoridades
senegalesas han cambiado la situación
después de una buena hora de viaje el
convoy llega a una tierra mítica el
bosque bao pack de mandiá ya dañado por
la explotación del suelo este lugar
simbólico corre el riesgo de sufrir
daños ambientales irreversibles una vez
más debido a los planes de ampliación de
una planta de cemento salvar la
naturaleza y respetar el medio ambiente
es el tema elegido por la diseñadora
como línea adam fundadora del evento
este año fue malo y no sólo para
nosotros menos mal tuve esa otra opción
de respaldo tuvo el fatto me aleje para
quedar en medio de la nada en este campo
de baobabs
la idea es realmente mantener la
corresponsabilidad y mostrar que podemos
desfilar en medio de la nada con un
mínimo
alcanza
hace 18 años decidiste organizar una
semana de la moda porque tuviste esta
idea porque me gustaba la moda porque
era una joven estilista que empezaba
porque era mi país y volvía de francia
donde había una semana de la moda y
pensé por qué no tenemos una porque
pensaba que la moda era realmente genial
es una fuerza económica una fuerza
estética incluso una fuerza política
porque también luchas por la igualdad
entre hombres y mujeres
por la paridad por la ecología
por la sostenibilidad por la artesanía y
por nuestro arte
oxidante nos ha enseñado a nosotros las
colonias a copiar los más o menos y
finalmente debemos encontrar una medida
justa con lo que somos y lo que es el
mundo
eso es lo que intento implementar que
tengamos bus que desfile mos en una cosa
de baobabs pero con vestidos muy
modernos que traiga de vuelta a estas
bellas damas que sólo conocen lugares
acogedores y bonitos hay muchas actrices
allí muy conocidas y creer en esta idea
de que podemos mostrar una hermosa
diferencia
cuando nació la semana de la moda de
dakar a principios de los años 2000
factor júpiter touré era muy joven se
convirtió en actriz y luego en directora
hoy no duda en seguir los pasos de adam
a los estereotipos que tengo que superar
son quizás los que preocupan a los
jóvenes de mi generación que no se
confía en nosotros porque todavía no han
visto de que somos capaces
adama y otras mujeres jóvenes también
que muestran el camino realmente nos dan
coraje a dama desafío a los diseñadores
invitados a que mostraran las culturas
africanas con un enfoque de la
corresponsabilidad
la diseñadora franco senegalesa rama dio
reclama una moda urbana internacional
este año elegí trabajar en todo tipo de
vélez
así que ve los de todo el mundo el que
fue el velo mauritano y de hecho tenemos
muchos velos aquí en áfrica un
taparrabos tejidos mezclar todas esas
influencias para hacer una colección que
sea a la vez glamorosa y el
corresponsable es un objetivo para este
año
con seis a un caballo vino de bissau
aboga por una moda fluida y fresca
eligió usar solo productos naturales
como aquí cebollas
trabajamos solo con lo que teníamos en
mi país guinea bissau es tejido y los
tintes el batik que hicimos es todo lo
que viene de las habichuelas verdes
elvis up todo lo que podemos encontrar
que puede teñir telas el algodón lo
hacemos he hecho todo lo posible para
entrar en este escenario lo cual me
parece genial
una vez resueltos los problemas de
organización porque no es fácil combinar
dos desfiles en uno a dama abre con una
colección de sedas salvajes decoradas
con bordados mauritanos
la diseñadora marroquí y cada lugar y
con sede en dakar dedica su colección a
los océanos
como lo hace ramas diaw que aborda en
sus vestidos los problemas causados por
el calentamiento global en su ciudad de
san luis al norte de dakar
piedras de imitación y purpurina
recicladas paramos a día con su marca
personal y el diseñador de dakar y nueva
york- cercano de las kardashians suele
vestir a beyonce les gustó a me pareció
genial un momento es mágico que la luz
la música y toda esta variedad de
creadores todas estas propuestas son una
maravilla
todos esos modelos en sus mejores
atuendos fue maravilloso
por culpa de la pandemia era décimo
octava edición de la moda de dakar no
terminara como de costumbre con una
fiesta delirante sino con imágenes
fantasmagóricas en homenaje al rey de
los bosques senegaleses el baobab